bonjour Sylvain Maillard bonjour Merci
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes député de Paris vous dirigez
actuellement le groupe Renaissance et le
groupe des députés de la majorité
présidentielle et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice wesser Redon du
groupe Ebra bonjour Fabrice bonjour à
vous et on va parler évidemment pour
commencer de le chien Viking puisque la
France a donc accueilli ce navire de
l'ONG SOS Méditerranée vendredi et ses
234 migrants qui ont donc débarqué à
Toulon après le refus de l'Italie de
l'accueillir est-ce que la France a plié
face à l'Italie la France c'est honoré
elle a un bateau était
depuis 15 jours avec 234 réfugiés en mer
sans trouver un port d'attache les
Italiens ont failli alors devoir et les
français eux ont fait preuve d'humanité
et donc nous avons accueilli de façon
exceptionnelle ce bateau avec 57 enfants
57 enfants donc nous ferons nous ferons
notre travail ils vont être dispatchés
en fonction d'une clé de répartition un
peu classique
qui a lieu pour tout l'ensemble des
réfugiés à travers différents pays
l'Allemagne en particulier pour que
chacun puisse trouver tous ceux qui ont
droit et qui auront le droit de rester
en Europe
sur l'Italie on va revenir sur l'Europe
mais un mot sur l'Italie vous dites
l'Italie a failli est-ce que vous
comprenez genre jamais Lee qui a
accueilli 90 000 migrants depuis le
début de l'année qui a fait campagne
elle vient juste d'être élu elle a fait
campagne sur le fait que l'Italie
n'accueillerait plus de migrants vous
comprenez pas son choix du coup c'est 57
enfants qui sont depuis 15 jours sur un
bateau seul dans des conditions que l'on
connaît avec des manques de manque de
nourriture et que on puisse se poser la
question si elle a fait son devoir
écouter tout simplement elle a pas fait
son devoir de femme ou d'homme tout
simplement est-ce que vous pensez que la
décision de l'État français aurait été
différent d'accueillir ce bateau
j'entends si ce bateau n'était pas
arrivé à un autre moment dans un autre
timing que celui de cet incident avec
ses députés RN qui suggérait de renvoyer
les migrants en Afrique et pour lequel
vous savez sanctionné oui non mais je
parfaitement je connais parfaitement
l'incidence j'étais coeur à ce moment-là
je le rappelle des spectateurs
on est dans une situation d'humanité et
le président de la République le
Gouvernement doit faire face à un
problème d'humanité et donc on a besoin
de trouver un port d'attache pour 250
migrants dont 57 enfants dont certains
en bas âge qui sont presque naufragés au
milieu de la Méditerranée c'était à
l'Italie des accueillir et ensuite il y
avait vous savez l'Italie n'aurait pas
accueilli tous ces réfugiés ils partent
une grande partie d'entre eux en Italie
on accueille beaucoup moins que
l'Espagne que la France que le
l'Allemagne par exemple mais après le
travail se fait classique développement
parlons de le dire de
dispatchement des des réfugiés elle n'a
pas voulu le faire parce qu'elle a voulu
faire un geste politique et donc on va
pas glorifier un geste politique qui est
un geste manque d'humanité pour des gens
qui sont tout simplement pour faire la
semaine prochaine évidemment pour
pouvoir faire le même titre exceptionnel
vous l'avez dit Gérald Darmanin le dit
Olivier Véran le dit en insistant que
c'est à titre exceptionnel ça veut dire
que si demain dans une semaine dans un
mois il y a un nouveau bateau qui est
qui se présente et que Georgia mélony
refuse de l'accueillir la France ne
l'accueillera pas non plus je pense que
je pense que le gouvernement italien va
réfléchir aussi à la situation parce que
vous avez raison la situation va se
reproduire nous on a dit une chose très
simple si l'Italie ne joue plus son rôle
à ce moment-là nous nous récupérons plus
les réfugiés qui sont à l'heure actuelle
en Italie un peu plus 3500 devaient
partir vers la France ou les prendrons
plus la l'Italie devra supporter le coup
et l'organisation mais je crois que
l'Europe ça ne prend pas les réfugiés à
sa charge vous vous dites on va en
prendre encore moins que ce qu'on pense
ils sont au pouvoir depuis 15 jours 3
semaines il y a évidemment
une mise en mise en route et parfois
peut-être en tout cas on l'a qualifié
comme ça peut-être d'un certain
amateurisme sur la question je crois
qu'il y a pas de question là-dessus sur
lesquelles au fond un pays peut
s'exempter de son devoir et il le paiera
cher si c'est le cas nous nous avons dit
une chose très simple il y a des
naufragés on les récupère on fait notre
devoir d'humanité je pense que on peut
être fier de la France de ce qu'elle a
fait et pour l'Italie ça leur donnera un
peu de temps pour réfléchir à la
situation
vraiment avant de parler de Gérard
Collomb puisque hier Bruno Retailleau
mais aussi le rassemblement national
pose la question des subventions
accordées à des ONG comme SOS
Méditerranée est-ce que pour vous il
faut continuer à subventionner ces
associations
le débat il existe et
c'est au fond c'est bien qu'il puisse
exister parce que c'est vrai que on peut
toujours se poser des questions il y a
eu beaucoup de reportages et quelques
années sur SOS Méditerranée moi ce que
je vois c'est c'est un bateau qui a
récupéré des naufragés et qui cherchent
à sauver entre autres je vous le redis
plus de 50 enfants voilà il fait un
devoir d'humanité auxiliaire des
passeurs oui oui mais je pense que c'est
après il est en campagne il est en
campagne pour pour son parti et moi je
voilà on est on est tous beaucoup
d'entre nous père et mère de famille on
réfléchit aussi comme ça au moment il y
a un devoir d'humanité on est français
c'est notre honneur
et si même si on subventionne pas est-ce
qu'il y aura plus il y aura plus les
bateaux c'est bien que les bateaux
seront là quand même donc il faut la
question est pas savoir si on ne paye on
ne donne plus d'argent la question de
savoir ce qu'on fait de tous ces
migrants qui viennent vous savez les
années qui viennent feront que
le débat sur les migrants tu devras sera
de plus en plus importante
subventionner ces associations non ça
fait pas partie du devoir d'humanité ça
fait juste partie du de d'un faux nez de
croire que si on ne donne plus d'argent
à tel ou tel ONG il y aura plus de
bateaux de migrants qui viendra en
France ou en Europe c'est un faux nez et
vous savez la pression quand vous avez
vous avez faim vous avez soif que vous
partez de votre pays en réalité on
pourra construire les murs aussi haut
qu'on le veut on pourra tout empêcher
les femmes et les hommes voudront tenter
un autre destin c'est comme ça donc
réfléchissons continuons à accompagner
la politique que nous menons depuis des
années pour faire en sorte de développer
ces pays leur donner un destin que
chacun d'entre eux est un destin là où
il habite critiques elles ne sont pas
que du côté de l'opposition elles sont
aussi dans votre camp puisque dans une
interview au point Gérard Collomb ancien
ministre de l'Intérieur fustige le choix
d'accueillir le chien Viking il parle je
le cite d'un tournant dans la politique
migratoire d'une brèche créant un
précédent cela ne peut concerger les
réseaux de passeurs quand dites-vous je
crois que c'est une erreur de Gérard
Collomb vraiment je sais à quel point et
quand il est parti de Beauvau je me
rappelle encore de conversation que nous
avons eu
ce l'immigration et le la gestion des
flux migratoires étaient devenus pour
lui une véritable obsession et au fond
quand vous êtes dans ce rôle c'est
normal c'est c'est pas travail de faire
en sorte de de réguler d'organiser
l'arrivée en France mais je crois que
c'est une erreur c'est encore un de je
le redis un devoir d'humanité de ce que
nous avons fait qu'aurions-nous dit si
nous avions laissé ce bateau continuer à
errer en plein milieu de la Méditerranée
avec des femmes des hommes et des
enfants qui n'ont plus d'eau plus aucun
espoir si ce n'est d'être
les les derniers de la terre parce que
personne les acceptait aurons-nous dit
on serait on sera en train de faire la
même émission vous dire mais vous n'avez
au fond pas de coeur la France n'est pas
capable l'Europe n'est pas capable
d'accueillir 250 migrants qui sont en
pleine détresse au milieu de la
Méditerranée
c'est pas la même situation ça fait 15
jours que le bateau était accepté nulle
part l'Aquarius c'était pas la même
chose qu'un jour et en plus avec
beaucoup d'enfants à bord et une
situation extrêmement dégradée et et on
voit un bras de fer avec l'Italie qui ne
fonctionnera pas à court terme donc il
nous fallait l'accueillir et je crois
que c'est soyons en fier moi je voudrais
vraiment vous dire soyons fiers de ce
que nous avons fait on est français et
on a accueilli on a tendu la main à des
réfugiés qui t'étaient en grave danger
voilà tout simplement à part cette
situation d'urgence ce que dénonceur
collant c'est la non prise en main une
réaction pas assez forte du gouvernement
et d'Emmanuel Macron face à cette
question migratoire
globalement est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui l'État français a pris en un
sujet à l'État national et au niveau
européen moi c'est un tout vous avez
raison c'est évidemment pas on parle
d'un bateau à un moment mais ça donne
tout la politique migratoire qu'est-ce
que c'est la politique migratoire c'est
de donner la chance à ceux qui viennent
en France dans des conditions régulières
qui sont qui ont qui remplissent les
critères de pouvoir rester pour
construire leur vie en France si le
souhaitent avoir un travail pouvoir
avoir une famille faire faire en sorte
que l'immigration font soit une chance
et c'est une chance pour eux c'est une
chance pour nous et à côté de ça que
ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à rester en
France doivent partir je crois que c'est
la politique qu'on mène depuis cinq ans
qui veut une politique très ferme et de
l'autre dans la majorité il y a ceux qui
veulent accueillir tout le monde il y a
des divisions personne ne va accueillir
tout le monde ce n'est pas vrai la ligne
de Gérald Darmanin et la ligne qui est
la ligne du gouvernement et la ligne de
la majorité il faut mieux aider ceux qui
arrivent
dans des meilleures conditions parce
qu'ils ont vocation à rester en France
ceux qui ont qui ont évidemment les
papiers les autorisations par contre
ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à rester en
France doivent repartir c'est tout notre
travail toutes les difficultés sur les
occuts dont vous parlez régulièrement
parce que renvoyer quelqu'un qui qui n'a
pas voté sur un enfant il faut une
autorisation du pays pour le retour et
ces autorisations sont parfois
difficiles à obtenir allez on va parler
du Parlement on commence par la
dissolution comme la tentation serait
grande de dissoudre un petit temps du
côté de l'Élysée et elle n'effraie pas
Marine Le Pen qui verrait une occasion
de se débarrasser des républicains
est-ce que vous vous êtes prêt à prendre
ce pari de la dissolution demain après
demain vous savez quoi ce sera le
marronnier des cinq années la
dissolution tous les six mois ça va
ressortir j'ai entendu dire j'ai
rencontré une personne qui m'a dit que
sera pas avant la fin du quinquennat
mais je n'en sais même je en tout cas je
fais pareil que moi c'est 5 années ce
sera le note marronnier toutes les 5
vous comprenez est-ce que c'est une
stratégie de il y a aucun projet de
dissolution je vous le dis et je vous
regarde dans les yeux aucun projet de
dissolution sur la table actuellement
aucun c'est une note qui existait dans
mon parti Renaissance comment on
s'organiserait en cas de dissolution et
qui a été qui a fuité et derrière votre
confrère le Journal du dimanche on a
fait une histoire tout simplement il n'y
a aucun projet de dissolution le
l'assemblée travail bien notre majorité
elle est relative certes pour le moment
tous les textes sont pas la première
fois de la République dit sous une
assemblée pour retrouver une majorité
claire mais vous avez raison mais je
vous le dis encore une fois je peux pas
être plus clair que ça il n'y a aucun
projet de dissolution actuellement dans
les cartons c'est un danger
de dissoudre aujourd'hui mais quel est
l'intérêt moi je me bats avec une
majorité j'ai la chance de conduire avec
berger une majorité qui passe tout les
textes on a encore tout à l'heure on va
commencer la locmin donc la loi
d'orientation se programmation sur du
ministère de l'intérieur
on va aussi réussir à le faire adopter
puis ensuite on aura les EnR on a et
tous les autres textes pour le moment
toujours sont toujours passés donc
pourquoi dissoudre puisque ça fonctionne
plutôt bien et c'est vrai que c'est plus
confortable je vous avoue j'ai connu
surtout le sur tous les textes
on en a eu besoin juste sur les budgets
et encore sur le budget parce que à un
moment on est à des des nombres
d'amendements qui est ingérables donc
voilà un moment il faut arrêter d'avoir
besoin sur les retraites
oui bah nous on veut toujours discuter
et ne pas utiliser le 49-3 on l'utilise
quand il y a un blocage quand il y a un
blocage sur le budget quand l'ensemble
des oppositions vous dit de toute façon
je ne serai pas le budget vous avez bien
compris qu'il y a pas d'autres
possibilités alors là
une
solutions ont voté un allongement de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans c'est ce qui demande depuis des
années avec 43 et unités pour la
génération 67 sauf que le gouvernement
s'y oppose c'est pas le meilleur moyen
d'éviter un blocage
non pas par principe il s'y oppose par
l'opportunité de déposer maintenant un
amendement et de décider dans le PLFSS
du Sénat comment va s'organiser la
retraite sur la forme mais sur le fond
c'est le bon curseur
qui est intéressante disons-le c'est pas
si éloigné des propositions qui a fait
le le président de la République la
seule chose c'est qu'il faut qu'il
discuter avec les partenaires sociaux
parce que ce que ce que ce dont non pas
parler les sénateurs par exemple la
pénibilité
avons fait en sorte que
cet allongement que nous on souhaite
parce qu'on pense que les Français une
phase générale doivent travailler plus
plus longtemps pourquoi parce qu'on a
financé non seulement notre modèle
social aussi la transition écologique
vous en parlez tout à l'heure
l'hôpital plus de policiers il va nous
falloir plus de services publics et donc
pour ça il va falloir plus d'argent et
donc plus de rentrée fiscale donc il
faudra travailler plus
pour vous c'est une bonne base c'est une
discussion qui est dans l'air du temps
après pour le moment on a besoin que les
partenaires sociaux puissent nous rendre
une feuille et une discussion plus
globale entre autres je vous dis sur la
pénibilité et sur les conditions d'accès
à cet âge légal je crois que les sons
les sons le c'est ce qui a choisi
Elisabeth borne et je crois que c'est un
bon choix laisser le temps à la
discussion et nous avons déjà dit nous
aurons une modification des retraites à
l'été au plus tard 2023 2023 sur le
budget puisque là il y a eu 49-3 à
l'Assemblée il y a notamment des
divisions dans votre majorité sur la
question des supers dividendes est-ce
que vous souhaitez que cette taxation
des super dividendes reviennent via un
amendement au Sénat je l'ai déjà dit sur
cet amendement de mon collègue Mattei
cet amendement il est pour qui est lui
aussi l'habitude de le poser en fait
année après année
d'abord une importante assez peu
d'argent et dans son fonctionnement
lui-même je pense qu'il y a une certaine
perversion je vous donne juste un
exemple si vous êtes un investisseur
individuel vous avez moins intérêt à
investir du fait de ces moments si tu es
adopté vous avez moins intérêt à
investir dans une entreprise française
que dans une entreprise américaine par
exemple pareil si vous êtes une holding
avec un front d'investissement vous
n'êtes absolument pas taxé alors que le
particulier à côté qui achèterait la
même action lui est axé sur du bien on
voit on voit bien que c'est au-delà de
de pas forcément fonctionner
parfaitement il est injuste et
contre-productif par rapport à nos
entreprises
la discussion elle était très symbolique
moi était à l'Assemblée à ce moment-là
était très symbolique ou d'un seul coup
on dit il faut qu'on évolue là dessus
pas à travers cette amendement là
réfléchissons plus globalement si on
veut le faire sur la fiscalité en
n'oubliant pas une chose nous nous
sommes la majorité qui baisse ses impôts
nous on pense qu'en France il y a trop
d'impôts et depuis 6 ans que nous sommes
aux affaires nous avons fait que baisser
les impôts partout et on va continuer et
comme par hasard je vous ferai un frère
remarquer on n'a jamais autant de
rentrée fiscale depuis qu'on baisse les
impôts vous voyez c'est c'est c'est
c'est tout bonnement plus vous baissez
les impôts plus vous allez de rentrer
fiscale parce que les gens
donc les parce que les uns et les autres
investissent plus en France et la France
est devenue la première terre
d'investissement des des capitaux
étrangers c'est pas un hasard vous
évoquiez la pièce des impôts il y a
quand même une répercussion sur le
terrain sur l'explosion de la taxe
foncière
et comment vous gérez ça vous êtes élu
d'ailleurs Marie Anne Hidalgo a lancé
une augmentation de 50% la taxe foncière
sur Paris mais ça n'est pas qu'un
problème parisien non
c'est quand même la conséquence de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation vous
avez la taxe d'habitation elle est
compensée à l'euro près le reprend sur
toutes les municipalités quand vous
regardez les collectivités publiques
elles ont jamais eu autant d'argent
qu'alors actuel pourquoi elles ont une
part de l'or importante de la une
fraction de TVA donc extrêmement
dynamique cette année qui qui les
finances donc elles n'ont jamais autant
d'argent
on va pas rentrer
donc est sur le cas de Ninjago c'est
différent il y a aucune réforme de
structure depuis un nombre d'années
incroyable donc au fond on est sur un
train de vie qui est beaucoup plus
important on a fonctionné à niago
fonctionner sur les loyers capitalisés
donc c'est à dire qu'elle anticipait les
50 prochaines années des loyers des
bailleurs sociaux et puis elle
encaissait directement année après année
on a arrêté de dispositif qui était en
train de ruiner Paris pour sur le long
terme puis elle arrive plus à boucler
son budget elle fait pas les économies
on travaille pas 35 heures en Amérique
Paris est-ce normal il y a plus de
fonctionnaires américaines que que dans
dans l'Union européenne est-ce que dans
dans le fonctionnement même de l'Union
européenne à Bruxelles et à Strasbourg
est-ce normal je crois que c'est ça
veut dire que les collectivités qui
augmentent la taxe foncière ça veut dire
qu'elles ont un problème de gestion et
je vous parle du café
spécifique et je dis depuis très
longtemps et nous le disons nous dans la
majorité présentait et puis tu as
longtemps la ville n'est pas bien gérée
et donc un moment mais oui on paye
l'addition on est endetté énormément
entre l'entrée dan Hidalgo la fin et
l'entrée Ninjago la dette avait doublé
mais mais où va-t-on donc il faut des
réformes de structure à Paris il faut
une meilleure organisation faut que la
ville et la structure de Paris coûte
moins cher et arrêtez en permanence de
vouloir augmenter les impôts s'il y a
pas que ça il y a toutes les taxes
évidemment stationnement qu'on peut
augmenter et au fond c'est quoi le but
c'est en fait c'est qui est plus de
parisien on a perdu moi dans ma
circonscription je suis du cœur de Paris
dans le 8e arrondissement l'année
dernière j'ai perdu 8% d'habitants 8%
d'habitants les gens ne veulent plus
habiter à Paris donc il y a un moment il
faut changer cette politique et faire en
sorte que les impôts arrêtent
d'augmenter à Paris
sur la prochaine texte qui sera examiné
à l'Assemblée c'est un texte sur la
corrida du député Emeric Caron qui
appartient en groupe la France insoumise
et qui veut interdire la corrida qu'elle
sera votre position sur ce texte écoutez
j'ai une position qui est très claire à
titre personnel c'est connu je suis
opposé au cora pour le fonctionnement du
groupe nous avons décidé puis un bon
bouton maintenant d'avoir une liberté de
vote absolue dessus par contre il y aura
une expression du groupe
plus forte qui dira tout simplement les
les tests que développent et Mike Caron
sur
l'anti-chasse anti-pêche tout toute sa
philosophie nous sommes opposés et
frontalement et le groupe Renaissance
est opposé frontalement à ce qu'il pense
et un point précis sur lequel il y a
discussion c'est sur la corrida et donc
sur la corrida il y aura une liberté et
une liberté de l'ensemble des
moi je l'ai déjà dit je suis contre je
contre la corrida je voilà
mais encore une fois moi je veux qu'il y
ait une expression du groupe qui dit
très clairement qui est notre position
par rapport au test des moyens plus
généralement cette couronne
philosophique mais à côté ça il y aura
sur ce point précis de la corrida qui
est quand même qui a un point je
comprends bien que ça cristallise et qui
est quand même un point très annexe en
France
mais moi j'interroge on verra la nups
les votes à nups on verra au RN les
votes on verra au LR les votes on verra
dans l'ensemble des parties vous verrez
que ce stade du sujet glissant c'est un
sujet client surtout un sujet qui au
fond et et moins poétique c'est plus
perception culturelle et perception d'où
là où on veut aller dans les années vous
parlez vous parlez de philosophie
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
la philosophie d'américain Caron pour
vous bah c'est une philosophie qui était
qui était au fond de pêche plus de
de pu manger de viande c'est le rapport
à l'animal c'est oui tout à fait c'est
un peu
très très éloigné en fait de ce que
porte la France et notre culture
générale donc moi je suis dans un
extrémisme qui pour moi ne correspond
pas du tout à ce qui nous faut par
contre c'est vrai sur le point précis de
la corrida c'est quelque chose qui voilà
moi
me heurte sur le bien-être animal on a
voté il y a quelques années la fin des
animaux
des animaux sauvages dans les cirques on
pourrait dire aussi que c'était la
culture du cirque d'avoir des animaux
sauvages et ça s'entend ça se respecte
et les professionnels disaient mais
c'est pas possible de faire ça mais je
crois qu'il on est dans un changement
d'air et donc il faut un moment
s'adapter et moi ça me semble assez
logique et je le dis regardez regardez
nos voisins Catalans qui l'ont depuis
très longtemps interdit la corrida et
c'est aussi c'était aussi dans leur
culture
un dernier mot sur l'assemblée l'arrêt
maladie d'Adrien cadenas arrive à être
échéance est-ce que pour vous il doit
revenir à l'Assemblée nationale il est
député donc un député il est payé par
notre par nos impôts pour faire son
travail donc ou bien il est en arrêt
maladie c'est ce qui était a priori le
cas depuis deux mois et à ce moment-là
il est évidemment exempté comme
n'importe quel personne qui travaille ou
bien il n'est pas en arrêt maladie il a
travaillé après il va être dans une
situation compliquée je pense dans son
groupe au sein au sein de l'assemblée à
lui de réfléchir savoir s'il peut
continuer son mandat ça veut dire qu'il
pourrait démissionner
il a reçu la légitimité du des Lillois
donc voilà mais je pense que c'est dans
une situation au sein de son groupe au
sein de son groupe au sein de
l'assemblée qui va être compliqué pour
lui et donc
honnêtement il y a pas d'accueil à faire
il y a pas voilà nous c'est un député
comme un autre on est un peu on est
juste gêné on va voir comment il va
faire parce que je pense pas qu'il peut
rentrer sur la pointe des pieds il va
falloir que lui aussi nous explique ce
qui se passe et comment il conçoit un
mandat parce que si au fond il revenait
que la vie continue ça veut dire que
beaucoup de choses pour les femmes
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses donc on
va voir et on va voir comment il a su
mais je commence son groupe assume cette
situation voilà je suis évidemment
embêté embêté dans dans le contexte mais
au fond je pense qu'il y a une décision
assez ferme à prendre de son groupe je
suis curieux de voir si ils ont toujours
un mot extrêmement désagréable pour tout
le monde on va voir comment ils vont
faire pour pour s'en occupe madame
Rousseau c'est pas du même groupe mais
enfin ils sont quand même dans la même
équipe j'ai envie on va regarder comme
si Madame Rousseau a même comportement
avec lui que avec les autres qui ne sont
pas membre de celle du peste merci
beaucoup Sylvain Maillard avec nous
merci Fabrice on passe au club des
territoires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]